o o
[Alkış]
Bu Ojeler et Hoşgeldiniz Alkışlar duymak
çok güzel gerçekten
[Alkış]
Çünkü Keşke şarkıcı Olsaydı keşke
olsaydı diyorum Çünkü sahneyi
bize
soğuk
[Müzik]
kamera ve
belki
de o yüzden o
bu şöyle bir şey yok Oğuz gibi videoda
tek başına müsaade konuşan bir araç ile
buluşup makineleri Çok iddialı
konuşuyor
Ne kadar tuhaf o
o vakit olmuş
mi Evet ben yaptırmış Bu aile veriyor
aynı zamanda
Hepimiz konuşuyoruz da ben kendi
kalktığında o ki ne su sorunu bile
oluyor kameraya şey taksicilerle bir şey
söyle de biz ne yapmaya çalışıyorsunuz
insanları diye bağlıyorsunuz ve kameraya
Karşı ki şekerlerde bu
[Müzik]
çok
şükür ya
o sırada o kötüsün yurtluk ev
filtrasyonun da Orkun dragao Stadı'nda
Almanya'daki gel sen kendi ki Aleyna'ya
kadar hepsine gittim
kablo bana ve o
odada özellik var sabahlar tıklatıp
30041 partı tadı kafasına göre alıcı hiç
dolu Herkes o
en ucuz ki Allah ahlaklı tuhaflık var
Sonra şu çıkıyor Ben Türkiye'de ilk
başlarımız olduğu dünya sağlığının
otobiyografik yazan yazıyı etiyle başlar
11'de başladı ve şöyle başladı
Ocak attığı esnasında tarih hoşuna ve
sinir 17 18 yaşındaki halinden
bahsediyorum ya bu çocuk nasıl oluyor bu
yaşlı boşları yakalayıp bu dünya
yıldızları arasında olma şansım Ne oldu
daha çok
[Müzik]
bu
tarz artırmamız gerekiyor Eğer sizde
başarım orası İsa
sizi ayağından daha böyle bir Hadi hadi
biraz daha
vazgeçmediği
şimdi o
bu yazılar eksik ölü bulunur
Ben bunu olmuyor videolar hemen
olmuş zaten
duyuyor o kalmıştı ama o
Ya hayır bunu olsun isterdim olmadı'
bu
alpert futbolcuları değil
yaptırmak besinin kapattık fotoğrafa
doğru resmi öbür Ronaldo ama
futbolu aldatmıyorum
burada ben ettiğini ve olduğundan
çalışmadığını anlatma Ben onları
hayatını anlatıyor
bu yazılmaz ki bu da olmaz ki futbol
seyredilir ha aşırı kısmı İşte o
anlatılır
o Çünkü öyle şeyler mı çağırsak ile
şarkı söylüyoruz zaten
yazarsanız çok görmez
aldım Bütün imkanları esas-ı
[Müzik]
da Google'da söylenecek söz bu ama
vazgeçmedik maddesi
ve o
da şekilde iki odayı
aile kardeşim çok şükür
için yazı yazmaya çalışıyoruz
O biraz Ne yapıyorsun O 30 yıllık dökmek
istiyorum ama çamaşır makinesinde sadece
bunu alıyorum iki metrekare biraz daha
yapacağız ya tavana
bu öyle işaretli ondan sonra sen bana
Kastamonu Samsun Bafralı hakkâri'de
artık size uçuşu Deniz Ya ben Buradan
çıkıp da nasıl başarılı göstereceğim
sakın sakın
o değil
Oh Oh Olsun adeyyo
adeyyo indir
bu şöyle iddaalar bana iki tane otobüs
bileti var Dünyanın neresine koyarsan
koy Ben de eve gelirim ama ben şey demem
Ama
gerçekten
odan Eğer hala çıkıp sihirli manısa
kusura bakmasın bafra'daki köyde yaşayan
Samsung bir sen temiz ama çok
hikayesini yazarken ağladım
Bu ikisi de babasıyla trafik kazası
geçirmiş iki tane 802a
bir futbol olabilir o kadar oynamaz var
ama o iyidir ne kadar kağıtlarda
çalışıyor şarkı söylüyor bize transfer
olduktan sonra bir sene sonra da bayağı
bir şey Riko ya
Bu nasıl anlaşma
çok aşırı bu lisede
Ben
her zaman şunu
12 haberlerde kızar bana göre koyuyorum
bir
bu
aktiviteleri hayal edecek haddini
bilerek dedim Ben küçükken
olacak pilot olacağım hayal etmesi Bu
gözlükler oldukça az
çalışacağım
anlatacağım
[Müzik]
Çünkü o
bu ve sosyal hissediyor 232 olmayı biz
artık o anlatılanların tam yerine oluyor
çok seviyorum Eda e
o Çünkü ben yaşamda
ama işte bir şey
koşmuşum şeyler yapmışım onun için öyle
bedava olmuyor Evet doluyor ikisi de
[Müzik]
Sen nasıl anlatsam bana hoşuma giderdi
kendi yerine koyuyorum sonra diyor ki
yapmışsın oluşan kompleks bir varlık
değil ki herkesin hemen etimiz bütün ya
da aynı şeyleri
güzel zamanı elimizden geldiğince
konforlu yaşamak sevdiklerimiz yanımızda
olsun değil mi değerlerimiz yargı
geldiniz az soğuk birbirleriyle aynı
arada farklılıklar politik ayrılıklar
olsa da iyice sonunda günü başlatıyoruz
güzel kesiyoruz
bitiriyoruz ama o o
[Müzik]
bu önemli bir mesaj vereceğini
düşünüyorum bu kadar alıp başını Yıllar
İçinde anlatmaya çalıştım da hem diyorum
ki kansızlık larda Zirve çıkartmış
saldırın hayatları kayda Değerdir Çünkü
o yapsa buradaki çocukla yapabilir Örnek
var Önünde
ise altın kaşıkla doğmadı beni yazdığı
kitaplarda özellikleri ve genç kızlara
yazdım o değişik hikayelerde de aynı
kokuyu yapıyor ortada 4'ü
[Müzik]
O benle Dacia Duster
Evet bakım burayı dinleyeyim ben
Almanya'dan Türkiye'ye geldiğinde orta
Biz de bilmiyorum
abone ol
de içeride iki hafta kendi vatanında
yabancı
yabancı olmaya çalışıyor
zaten
hala
yabancısın
Almanca'yı
ne kadar zeki ve
[Müzik]
son değil mi dağılıyor anlamıyorum
bilmiyorum Çok engebeli biliyorum su
biliyorum Allah ver böyle değişik
söyledin Bilmiyordum sonradan öğrendim
ben Hem de nasıl öğrendim işte
konuşuyoruz Çok şükür 25 yıldır en üst
düzeyde onu sağ medyada
ya kaderin cilvesine bakın ki haber
spikeri oldu bitter ol
bu kanal adı Türkiye ilk savaşı Köyü
benim
o zati Şampiyonlar Ligi'nde işte ilk
Şampiyonlar Ligi bir tanesinden 11
bu TV8
Kanal D
ama
gene tut üst düzey çalıştı 12 tane kitap
kitaplar Yani demek istiyorum ki bendy
ve başardıysan
[Müzik]
Ama gerçekten Türkiye Cumhuriyeti
topraklarında nerede yaşıyor olursa
olsun her genç
başarabilir Bu kadar basit ve umuyorum
o
hayalleriniz
iç ok özlemez de bitmeyiz Çünkü o
yaptığımızda kavuşmak zor olur Hiçbir
şey imkansız bir yeter kisi ama bu da
giden yolda ihtiyacımız olan şeyler bas
kelimeler
O ne iş yapıyor olursanız olumlu eğer
cihaziniz geçtiyse kendinizi ifade
ederken
olmanız gereken yerde belki
olmayabilirsiniz Çünkü kelimeler
yaptığınız işi ha parlatıcısı dır
aynısıdır ama o kelimelerini
çekmecelerde yeni gelip çıkarabilmek
için şok okumak lazım ve geliştirme
Birlik memleketin Güzel geçtiğine en
büyük dan sebep oluyor bir oldu gel diye
25 lira Evet bildiğiniz o kalori
ihtiyacı var alın Afiyet olsun Çok güzel
değil ama bir kitap 20 lira beynimizin
de kaloriye ihtiyacı var o da beslerim
zor değil bağlı değil yapalım ve
şirketler altını çizmek istiyorum zaten
söyleyeyim inadı Bu
gerçekten bir gibi bende kendine yabancı
bir bu olarak gelmiş biriyle ben bile
başarılı biliyorsan hepiniz
başarabiliriz Teşekkür ederiz
biz
a a